violent crime is surging in minnesota
it's surged over the past year it's up
17 total setting records for murders
ilhan omar's take on this
got to blame the cops
what
we must also recognize
is that the reduction in policing
currently in our city
and the lawlessness that is happening
um
is
due to two things
one the police have chosen
to not
fulfill
their oath of office
and to provide
the public safety they are owed
to the citizens they serve
right it's documented
but even before that it was documented
the minneapolis police department is the
most dysfunctional
police department in our state and
probably in the country
johann omar has such a sinister sounding
voice
that's beyond what she's actually saying
the way she talks it's like a movie
villain but what is she saying she's
saying
we must recognize that the reduction in
policing currently in our city and the
lawlessness is happening because the
police have chosen to not fulfill their
oath of office and protect the people
they said they'd protect this is this is
a big problem and she says the second
one is even before that it was
documented that the minneapolis police
department was very dysfunctional okay
but the thing is
she's pointing out that it's these two
problems
but we're focusing on the surge in crime
so when she says even before recent
events it you know the police part was
very dysfunctional okay but that's that
doesn't matter that's irrelevant because
we're talking about the change right
we're talking about the huge increase in
crime 17
increase in violent crime and new
records for murders so it's really just
number one ill honor saying the police
are refusing to do their job and protect
people what was ill hanomer saying last
year last year she said that the police
are a cancer and we quote we need to
completely dismantle the minneapolis
police department
do you get it yet
do you see this when the police do their
job and arrest criminals that is
terrible discrimination it's racist it's
evil it's white supremacy
we need to abolish the police okay then
the police don't arrest the criminals do
you know what that is it's racist it's
white supremacy they're not protecting
people they're not doing their jobs we
need to what do we need to do we need to
refund the police
what is it it's a rigged game is what it
is i love paint your life i could not
possibly be more impressed with paint
your life what is paint your life you
send them a photo or multiple photos of
a loved one of a place of a special
memory and they will create a hand
painted picture of it for you i like
mine in oil but they have other options
as well
i will be completely blunt
i did not think this could be a good
service i figured the art would be
amateurish and not great
so the first time i got one done i had
it done for my step-brother and then i
received the the hand-painted portrait
and it was beautiful it was incredible
so then i said i don't want all right
fine you can have this one because it
was of him and his wife but i said now i
want some for me i had one done of my
mother i'm having another one done now
it's just they're just beautiful they're
really and the price is unbelievably low
and it is such a special way to spruce
up your home have a cherished memory it
makes a great christmas gift at
paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed they will
work with you every step of the way you
can check on stuff uh right now is a
limited time offer you can get 20 off
your painting 20 off and free shipping
text michael mich ael to sixty four
thousand that is michael mich ael to
sixty four thousand
head on over to paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
term supply available paint your life
dot com slash terms how do you get it
text michael mich ael to 64 000.
anything the cops do
is evil and the cause of society's woes
there's nothing the cops can do right
now
that ilhan omar will not blame them for
it's the same thing with racism
you you notice this in particular
sometimes what the the left will say
if you
if you wear a sombrero
on halloween or cinco de mayo or
something that is cultural appropriation
if you
do your hair in a certain way if you
wear certain clothing that's cultural
appropriation that's racist
if you don't do that that's cultural
erasure
so if you don't eat tacos on cinco de
mayo if you don't
acknowledge these other cultures then
you're erasing then you're a white
supremacist because you're not
acknowledging mexican people or black
people or asian people
that's very racist
if you do
acknowledge those cultures you're also a
racist
because it's appropriating my culture is
not your costume or whatever they say
there's no way to win it's the same
thing with feminism do you remember i
remember this about three four years ago
no more than that now i guess
there was a big breaking shocking story
mike pence
that evil misogynistic my pants he
refused to cheat on his wife
so mike
big huge story mike pence would not go
on dinner dates with women who were not
his wife when his wife was not there
that sexist
that ah
that's awful he wouldn't allow women
to rise up the ranks
he wouldn't he was treating women
differently than he would treat men
so you've got to go on dinner dates with
women but then by the way you go on
dinner dates with women and you're a
metoo predator sexist
there's no there's no winning it's a
rigged game
the squishes
very often
give in to this
the people who say i'm a republican but
not that kind of republican they always
say i'm not a racist i'm not i'm not a
racist please i maybe we should reform
the police i must i'm not a
sexist i'm not
they don't care bro they don't care
ilhan omar doesn't care what the cops do
she's going to blame them for anything
these radical leftists don't care what
you white person or what you man or what
you
non lgbt elementop what you know you
straight person do they don't care
they're just gonna blame you for
everything
so maybe you should just follow your own
moral compass your own conscience okay
and just do the right thing and stop
trying to play their game their game is
rigged
i'm so glad you like that clip i like
that clip too but a lot of people i'm
sorry to say are not getting
notifications for these clips if you
want to get notifications ring the bell
subscribe more importantly head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play myspace xanga aol instant
messenger wherever you get your podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see
[Music]
[Music]